laura et david ont tout manigancé bravo
bonhomme vanilla ce mondial il a des
infos benji a laissé partir garde si on
essaie de véhiculer mis des quines et
ici à couper avec tout le monde
ce n'est pas vrai vous dit que c'était
prémédité de la peau massa ne faut aucun
doute que toute cette affaire a été
manigancé réfléchir
organisé par la partie adverse et vous
voulez dire avant la mort même de johnny
hallyday ça ne fait aucun doute pour moi
c'est à dire que les deux aînés santé
oppressante et qu'il serait écarté de
mon sens pas que ils le savaient ils le
savaient
ces paquets de santé le savez est en
fait il faut arrêter également que c'est
l'histoire de deux de ces personnes la
curée des déshérités
alors il dit que ses manigances et oui
juste avant quand même sans prendre
parti pour l'un ou pour l'autre mais
honnêtement la défense de laura et david
quand ils traitent laetitia de madame
boudou à laquelle les mailles depuis
vingt-quatre ans après voilà on va pas
sûr c'est pas possible de faire ça
honnêtement et là je pense qu'ils
enchaînent vraiment les minimes de
bêtise sur bêtise et que petit à petit
j'ai l'impression que l'opinion se
retourne tous les regards sur sa non non
non ça serait si les bretons aimeraient
qu'il est et faire entrer dans les
détails on se rend compte que petit à
petit quand même le choix de johnny
visiblement est pas un choix comme ça
que c'est un joueur et le roman réfléchi
ce qui l'a mis en place et compliqué à
mettre en place et je ne dis pas qu'ils
ont raison ou tort je dis que l'opinion
publique commence à comprendre que
peut-être foot - les klaxons ou tout
noir
comme lors de l'été c'est à très maligne
parce qu'elle les a laissés aller à la
charge dans un premier temps avec tous
les excès que ça pouvait comporter y
compris notamment
l'avocate de david qui est plutôt
extrêmement agressive est qui et qui
s'attaque à laetitia la personne
laetitia et pas simplement c'est
l'aspect j'aimerais que lui il avait
l'air très sympa j'ai la boite chirac
est quand ils ont plus de biscuits
contre attaque et bébé dans la bataille
de grand- dans la bataille de l'image de
la communication de l'éthicien elle est
tout bonnement extraordinaire parce que
quand vous voyez d'où ils sont partis et
ils ont retourné l'opinion suis d'accord
avec benjamin on est maintenant 51 49
mais d'où ils viennent
le clan l'éthicien à 80 ans à le gagner
vas tu sais moi jeté un pavé dans la
mare su ce que je veux dire la désirade
et dans une mare non
mais avant ça demande d'abord souligner
est surligné la com de laëtitia qui est
extraordinaire mais c'est vrai pas
pardon quand des choses sont bien faites
pour bravoure effet que sont le culv et
juniors qui s'est en revanche pas venant
la marque qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que si vraiment comme tu dis
johnny hallyday avait tout manigancé
il a donc sciemment déshériter ses deux
enfants et ça fait de lui un sale mec
donc on est en train de dire que tu
vraiment eu ce que tu dis à tête si tu
as raison c'est john eales salle même
c'est ça que tu es belle manière devant
une caméra que johnny est assez mais les
valeurs sûres fouet parce qu'il ya quand
même une meuf dans l'émission est comme
à ce but à l'heure et je la voyais que
mon jeu oui mais david et laura
[Applaudissements]
alors attendez à ce que l'avocat de
laetitia aussi donner son avis à propos
d'une éventuelle réconciliation entre
les différentes primes parce qu'il ya vu
cette rumeur comme quoi il fallait qu'on
savait qu'ils avaient trouvé un accord
regardez sa réponse ce qu'une
conciliation laetitia laura david est
possible ce matin je ne le pense pas vu
l'agressivité dans ma cliente a fait
l'objet je ne pense pas qu'elle soit
dans un état d'esprit qui tendent vers
une réconciliation je vous disais
bonjour le cible ni envisagera possible
sûrement possible sorman alors parce que
vous le savez les meilleures amies c'est
les midis et letizia ne manquera jamais
de temps de la valeur comme de laëtitia
est particulièrement réussi mais ce
qu'il faut quand même appuyé par dessus
tout c'est quand l'avocat de laetitia a
dit que tout ait manigancé davance de la
part de david et laura mais qui nous
montre les preuves entachées par la
chose et on n'est pas loin de la vérité
j'ai bien sûr du voile alors ça soit la
très subjectif tonneau qui dit qu'on n'y
aura pas de réconciliation est possible
voilà ça ce n'est pas possible